exercice grandeur nature ce matin
d'octobre pour tous les services du plan
orsec
trois bus en bout de piste de l'aéroport
roland garros afin de mettre en scène un
crash aérien
une simulation est essentielle car elle
peut permettre de comprendre les forces
et les faiblesses d'une intervention
collective
alors que les moniteurs placer les
bandelettes 1 êtes-vous passé du
national et des caps les photos en les
bombardant avait 25 de chaque
fonctionnaire et puis ça se dit ah vous
avez installé 25 se trouve à l'entrée de
golf à l'entrée du bois de la bretelle
golf et on attend les secours extérieurs
dont le commandant spa champ de secours
est fait par nos fils à pompiers qui
doit coordonner tous les moyens le
public et privé qui sont mises à sa
disposition pour secourir les gens donc
c'est à travers ce genre d'exercice que
nous travaillons cette coordination est
justement les services vont arriver
offert mesure permet de se caler par
rapport au départ de l'intervention où
on ne trouve que des pompiers nous
sommes là pour rodez toutes les
procédures qui ont été élaborées dans le
cadre du dispositif spécifique orsec
aérodrome roland garros et on est là
également pour appliquer le dispositif
spécifique orsec nombreuses victimes
qu'on appelle nos vies l'ambiance
factice a joué par les élèves de l'école
d'infirmières est pourtant présente pour
les secours alors comment être ordonnées
dans tout ce désordre
au début il ya plus de victimes que de
sauveteurs donc il faut s'adapter à
cette situation donc là on est en phase
de montée en puissance bientôt de
secours qui sont en route ils peuvent
pas être là tout de suite donc les
premiers arrivants qu'il soit premier ou
au médecin du samu doit faire face à un
plus grand nombre de victimes qu'ils ont
la capacité de traiter donc il faut
qu'ils s'organisent donc ils sont en
train de s'organiser
ils vont essayer de rassembler les plus
graves dans un endroit un peu plus
protégé les moins graves qui peuvent
marcher vont être regroupés sur une
autre zone pour pouvoir prendre en
charge le mieux possible tous les
patients en fonction de leur degré de
gravité les évacuer vers les hôpitaux
bracke
hier
pas mal apple
en fait la pratique
je me sens faible
parallèlement à cela les forces de
l'ordre doivent récupérer le maximum
d'informations une action pas toujours
facile
c'est alors une deuxième vague de
secours cette fois extérieur l'aéroport
qui arrivent sur le site
le passage d'information et des tâches
se doit être rapide et précise pariant
feu disloqué en plus attentifs d'accord
extinction cours moyen de trois lances
nombreuses victimes éparpillées sur une
grande surface et je confirme le renfort
de moyens extérieurs et déclenchement du
plan orsec dispositif disposition
spécifique à l'europe roland garros ok
ensuite quoi leur engouement de victimes
investigations suivent à la lettre à
michel qui continue la localisation est
mince affaire qui va en prendre un
risque de la curatrice de feu explorer
le bus bleu était ont été investigués le
bus moi je vais bien ternes
reconnaissance rapide et encore de
nombreuses victimes à l'intérieur du
parti d'avion qui encore et humanité et
le bus mois
on peut
rades habituellement en urgence absolue
à jans relative huerre ou impliqués en
fonction ça implique un terme de thézan
clique des délais de d'évacuation qui
sont pas les mêmes l'urgence absolue
bien évidemment passe en avant l'urgence
relative et quinquas une plaie du thorax
va être immédiatement évacué sur un
hôpital quelqu'un qui a une simple
blessure de la cheville sans pronostic
vital engagé pourra être évacués dans un
délai beaucoup plus long et au
priorisera les patients les plus gras
sur ça qu'il faut qu'on ait une idée
rapide des plus graves voire on prend
les à prendre en charge en première
alors bien évidemment dans ce type de
situation il ya un impact psychologique
peuvent faire les personnes qui sont pas
blessés sur le plan physique peuvent
être extrêmement traumatisés sur plan
psychologique dans le dans les plans de
secours
il y a aussi la mobilisation de
professionnels de psychologues de
psychiatres ce qu'on appelle la cub la
cellule d'urgence médico psychologique
qui va être mobilisée pas en même temps
que les pompiers que le samu parce qu'il
ya toujours un petit peu de délai pour
son arrivée mais elle va arriver dans
quelques minutes elle prendra en charge
les patients valide mais impliqué sur le
plan psychologique très des victimes va
se passer par là parce que tout passe
par le tout le monde passe par le pma le
pym's rappelé assez logiquement à
l'arrière en 38 heures 38 a eu assez les
urgences absolues qui sont expliquées et
hospitalisés de suite qui sont évacuées
les us vont être soignés ici évacué
après et en a 70 impliqué la cub c'est
la cellule d'urgence médico
psychologique donc dépendent
l'établissement public de santé mentale
de la réunion et qui est composée de
volontaires qui vont donc psychiatres
psychologues infirmiers spécialisés en
santé mentale qui viennent de toute la
réunion
bon eh ben il faut demander des chaises
parce qu'elles sont parties aux pma les
chaises vous n'avez pas des petites
choses chez vous à nous prêter
fait d'eux des petits coins vous savez
pour pour faire des petits j'ai trois
chaises partie coin voilà super génial
vous pouvez aller loin les chaises ça
fait partie de l'ensemble de
des principes c'est à dire de restaurer
un petit peu la dignité l'humanité c'est
des gens quand ils ont vécu quelque
chose de cet ordre là ils ont
l'impression d'avoir d'avoir tout perdu
jusqu'à leur propre humanité leur propre
dignité une chaise inverse que tout tout
tout ça pour nous c'est le cadre dans
lequel on permet de ré inscrire le sujet
ben du côté du côté de la vie ça peut
paraître anodin mais en même temps c'est
propre c'est des choses essentielles car
ici les gens qu'ils arrivent
sauf si un ring rascisme ils voulaient
ils sont mis sur les brancards
les gens voient là ils vont remarquer
que c'était l'avant un petit hôpital se
met dans place afin de soigner les
victimes mais également de les évacuer
mélangez puis tourne pas déjà vu assez
oui techniquement si vous mettez là
comme ça non non nous impliquer ils sont
plus envahis par le par le passage dans
cette voie là ça serait vraiment super
sympa de votre part parce qu'en fait la
la je pense qu'ils s'aggravent ou là ou
là mais importance de ces simulations
c'est d'apprendre à travailler ensemble
pas facile ce n'est pas facile
constamment chacun des préoccupations
très différentes à des fonctions très
différentes et des façons de penser très
différentes et la question des soins
psychologiques et pas forcément toujours
la priorité dans ce type 2
l'événement par jour je mangeais de
l'autre côté de la piste bien loin de
cette agitation la vie normale les
familles arrivent à l'aéroport pour
récupérer leurs proches des gens là où
une personne qui a pris entre n'arrête
pas de nous renvoyer à droite à gauche
on sait bien bien sûr je sais bien que
c'est un stress pour vous et tous
cependant il a de la cellule et léon
rouvrir mais là c'est l'absence
d'information ou encore leur véracité
exceet la foule face au personal de
comptoir qui doit à nouveau gérer et
après de longues minutes
l'autre partie de l'équipe de la cuma
arrive sur le site ya juste au niveau du
comptoir on les informe de monter dans
la salle et dans la salle il n'y a rien
hormis l'accès au téléphone pour la
préfecture pour avoir des infos
baïri dit on voilà nous sommes là on va
vous accompagner dans la salle lauga
rester avec nous c'est en retard ou
estime alors nous on est arrivés dès
qu'on nous a appelés donc le temps car
nous avons maintenant contre je trouve
vous savez nous on n'a pas déçu en ce
sens tant que psychologue nous avons
vécu des actionnaires on n'a pas de
gyrophare service de l'urgence mm on n'a
pas les outils pour voir sa famille des
passagers arrivent donc nous n'a pas
l'heur de l'information fait deux heures
que ça a été ça a été signalé d'accord
maintenant nous pouvait pas faire plus
vite maintenant on est là pour vous déjà
comment ça se passe pour vous
ici c'est très difficile pose plein de
questions
on n'a pas d'information important qu'on
puisse savoir qui est qui identifiait
les uns et des autres pour pouvoir
communiquer au plus haut plus vite pour
que dans ce genre de situation dans ce
type de cas les choses puissent se
mettre en place le plus rapidement
possible et de manière la plus
efficiente possible
les familles sont alors regroupés dans
une salle dédiée isolé du grand public
de l'aéroport
la prise en charge peut se faire de la
meilleure des manières
l'assistant trader
alors pour l'instant la chose à savoir
c'est que il y avait 17 ça l'a été
prêts mis à votre disposition pour que
les premières informations qui arrivent
nous soit donnée directement c'est à
dire qu'aucune information n'arrivera
normes un autre lieu avant cet endroit
là vous êtes les familles les proches
vous allez être les premières personnes
vous êtes les premières pousses un
délice à les premières alertes et c'est
une fausse information qui
pour le titre au format ne voulait pas
et la paix côté dames ma femme attendait
va bien madame pourquoi monsieur madame
ou bien des rumeurs d impression que le
temps est interminable vague de
secouristes est loin d'apaiser ces
familles inquiètes
non tu vois en attendant on nous tourner
en bourrique qua non mais c'est bon je
venais informations
il ya beaucoup d'émotions dans ces
moments là donc l'idée c'est d'être
présents pour les soutenir
faut pas être débordée par ses
ces émotions là vraiment c'est ça notre
mission principale la mise en place
d'une écoute téléphonique avec la
préfecture permis le recensement est
ainsi de croiser les informations une
communication pas toujours facile dans
un aéroport international
sur la piste les entretiens individuels
et collectifs se poursuivent avec les
impliquer ils vont très bien ils ont
très bien mais c'est à vous qu'il faut
demander comment vous avez mois sa femme
je suis pas blessé comment je loue santé
des chiens tout cas j'ai vu des morts
sur la piste et on a pris du temps à me
plonger par mail à juan mata n'y ait pas
d'accord vous inquiétez pas on vous
allez la voir
l'idée c'est de prévenir une pathologie
qu'on appelle le syndrome
psychotraumatiques qui peut avoir des
conséquences à long terme
donc en plus de pour certains d'être
endeuillé d'avoir perdu des membres de
leur famille d'avoir vécu cet événement
pour certains ça peut être des
cauchemars des images qui qui se
répètent à l'infini une dépression
beaucoup d'autres choses en terme de
symptômes on élève comme parfois dans la
réalité la conclusion peut être heureuse
la coordination et surtout le système
d'information dans ce type de
catastrophe
influence considérablement le scénario
qu'il faut absolument avoir ce type
d'exercice pour s'entraîner puis aussi
pour mettre en évidence qui ne va pas
pour que le jour où ça arrive réellement
on est cette expérience pouvoir
justement ne pas reproduire mon erreur
au mieux les affaires maintenant que le
jour vraiment y aura un type nous on
essaye d'être de prévenir au plus tôt le
dispositif vient avant que les gens
demandent mais on peut pas être sur
toutes les interventions sur tous les
événements et l'idée c'est de
sensibiliser la population au fait que
ce type d'événement peut avoir des
répercussions psychologiques qui peuvent
être importantes et qu'il faut pas
rester
et